In this chapter will provide the framework
for thinking about computer environments
that can be applied bows to your laptop
and scale up to supercomputers
by the end of this chapter
you will understand the fundamental concept of computer sources
and how they relate to each other
so what are computer sources simply
they're the components that make up a computer system
will have the cpu or central trusting union
which execute the most instructions will have memory
or ram which temporary holds data
and problem instructions
and we have gpus or graphics processing unions
which are designed for graphics rendering
but can also be used for general purpose computing task
requiring a lot of parallel processing
like scientific simulation data analytics or machine learning
these resources work together to execute programs
and each has its own unions of measure
for example cpu unions are measured in course
and clock speed while memory is measured in bites
in giga mega and terribytes
for each of our problems
we will need a set of resources
to execute the mo
is crucial to consider the resource require to execute them
efficiently the location where program components are executed
and the bandwidth of the infrastructure connecting them
play a significant role
in determining overall performance
for example a gp might be fest to compute specific parts
of our program but if loading our program to the gpose memory
takes more time than we say
it might be faster to use cperiod instead now
let's talk about skating classical resources
we have two approaches vertical scaling
and horizontal scaling vertical scaling involves incr
the power of a single resource
like using more powerful cpu already more memory
within one physical note
where note is a union of compute cluster encoupsulating multiple
resources within it could is until scaling
involves edding more sources
like multiple cpuse or jb use
to work together on a single note or multiple notes
both approaches have their own advantages
and disadvantages and the choice depends on the specific use
case in requirements less introduced in new type of resource
quantity resources quantum resources process quantum information
with a quantum proceed unit or kpu a keep eu
is the entire system responsible
for accepting an executable quantum instruction set
or quantum circuit and returning
and accurate answer that means
the keep you includes war on more more quantum chips
for example an ibm quantum here
as well as multiple additional components
in a dilution refrigerator
which called the quantum chip
such as quantum monthly fire control electronics
and the classical computer required
for tasks like holding instructions
and wave forms in memory accumulating results
and the future error correction decoding
in general quantity resources are measured
in terms of its quality the layered fidelity scale
the number of quantum bids
and the speed the circuit layer operations per
second or clops today will be treating the quantum chip
as a union of measure similar how resource management systems
treat gps not by the number of course
by the entire unions what about scaling
like classical resources the scaling of funda resources can
also be categorised into vertical
and horizontal vertical scaling
would be increasing the number of cubits per chiplet
or per chip
corresonal scaling would be connecting cheaps
wiscoplers or was classical interconnects
with the sort of definition out of the way
let's talk about resource management
resource management is a computer infrastructure refers
to the process of planning
allocating and controlling the use of computational resources
such as cpu memory storage
and that what bandwidth to ensure efficient
and effective resource utilization
you can think of resource management
as a multi dimensional game of deters where blocks
are you job requirements i
in each dimension as a resource unit the general task
is to fit this job blocks into cube of
all of your available resources resource management
is a very tricky task and different compute facilities implement
different tactics to configure their infrastructure
for the specific needs of their user base
to apply concepts that we just learn we're going to be using
slurm slurm is open source software
for resource management
for demonstration purposes i
have a local set up with three virtual notes
we can get information on those computer horses
by running slow control comment
would have two partitions or north groups
normal and quantum the normal partition is composed of notes
that have access to classical resources only
and the quantity partition has access to quantity resources
let's first on the simple
classical hello world example whistler
first we need hello world program itself.
And sure is our program which just printing hill
world.
Now we need to tell the resource manager
what resources we need to execute this program
as we discussed slurn provides a way to specify
all metal data for job by
which is just a shell script
with some slow specific annotations
this annotations owls you to specified a source requirement
scheduling parameter and more.
We can check our submission script
and here you have partition specification
how many notes we need how many tasks per note we're going
to execute how many cipils per task we will use
and which are script will want to run
and this is our hell world program.
To submit our job for execution will only need to run
one command which is learn betch
and provide our script as an arg
we can check execution q
and see our whole world program is running
on the normal partition on an old c one
one's job is finished we can check the results
looking at output file.
And that's it.
We're also interested in using quantity resources
as well therefore let's create a simple hello keys get program.
Here our kisket program which has all of the
necessary steps off circuit creation
optimisation execution and post processing.
And here all of the programming concepts that we talk
about quantum circuit transportation
and just get primitives
now we need to create submission screen
as before but here we specify
quantity resources requirements
since we specified the resources
and the partition of all cluster
what quantity resources are available
is get premiums will use
a located resources to execute quantum payments.
Now we need to run our program.
And one shop is done we can check the results.
And here's our expectation value.
And that's it for resource management
in the next section we're going to be talk
about programming models